thank you thank you very much
wow we have a
if you get a shot of this going on
look at this there's actual people
there's people
people thank you thank you jesus
i have people okay people
people a live audience are we making
history are we the first ones to do this
we're doing it we're doing it very
safely here everybody has been tested
socially distanced and compensated for
their time
like like the women at the bar at nobu
well this is interesting you can hear
people laugh individually at this
oh i see that guy like that joke and
that lady didn't that's an
interesting experiment anyway i'm so
thankful you're here
uh i'd say you're very brave but there's
like no [ __ ] chance you could get it
look at you you're a million miles
i mean you're you've been tested you're
masked you're spread way apart what we
in the business call ideal for comedy
but at least hey there's people
there's people and boy i picked a good
good week to get back to the studio with
people because the
forecast on my phone today i'm not
joking it said
smoke
tomorrow's forecast blade runner
the are you from los angeles
you're all local right of course okay
all right well
i mean jesus christ the air in los
angeles it was like a
cross between shanghai and my dressing
room
i'm saying there was a lot of i mean i'm
if i'm sniffling it's because yeah it's
[ __ ] out there i
i went to i went through a checkup
yesterday to my doctor he grabbed my
balls and said
turn your head and stop coughing
seriously
it's like [ __ ] mars out there
today elon musk looked out the window
and said finally i'm home
elon musk you know okay no there is so
much smoke in oregon right now uh you
can barely see the tear gas from the
riots
it's crazy out there the ash is falling
you've seen this it's like it's snowing
ash
it's it's like the 80s all over again my
nose is running and there's white powder
in my car
and this pissed me off i'm sure it did
you too right one of the fires
you saw this was because so many parents
were having a gender reveal party
in the park and the parents set off a
smoke bomb
that we would see if it would turn pink
if it was a girl and blew if it was a
boy
proving once again something i've always
said the wrong people are reproducing
and of course you might even have
electricity we have rolling blackouts
now here
right you know in l.a in california i
mean yesterday nancy pelosi had to get
her hair done by candlelight i i
and and uh president trump has been
monitoring the fires very closely he
said his heart goes out to the insurance
companies
oh he's full of empathy this guy i tell
you it was it's not it's 9 11
anniversary today
uh yeah and uh trump said he will never
forget the moment
uh when he learned that he had the
tallest building in manhattan
trump said that i you know because
because he's an [ __ ] you see
there you go there you go there you go
sometimes you have to think twice on the
thing it's like
you know the modern audiences don't get
that [ __ ] thing
but i tell you 2001 were you even alive
some of you people for that or you were
kids i tell you it's such a different
time i mean back then trump was a
punchline with no interest in governing
oh yeah
uh no i mean 19 years
everything is just so different i mean
back then if you ate on the sidewalk you
were either homeless or french
[Music]
and if you stayed six feet away from
someone it's because they smelled like
axe body spray that's you know
now it's cause the virus
but uh yeah the virus is apparently not
going away uh dr fauci said we're gonna
have to hunker down
uh because the fall is coming and it
could get even worse and
la county took him to heart boy today
they announced l.a county did
canceled halloween they have kept right
no trick-or-treating
no party [ __ ] i had a great costume this
year [ __ ] dr deborah burks
jesus
no i don't get to wear it now but
yeah it's so interesting dr fauci is in
bob woodward's new book he's got a new
book about trump called
rage and apparently dr fauci said
trump's attention span
is quote like a minus number
and when trump heard that he was furious
for about a second
and then somebody rattled a bag of
cheetos and he forgot all about it
but yeah trump guess that he held one of
his super spreader rallies
he's the president he has super spreader
rallies there in michigan and he
compared his handling of the virus to
fdr
the only thing he has in common with fdr
is they both had difficulty walking
you